To structure the N-tier applications we're going to
talk about one particular framework as an example.
It's just as an example, there are
other frameworks that provide similar functionality to the
JEE framework which is called the Java
Enterprise Edition framework. And in the JEE framework
there are four containers for constructing an application
service. And containers you can think of as
protection domains implemented typically in a Java
virtual machine. In the JEE version of, of
building N-tier applications there are four containers there
are the client contain and there is an
applet container for the client, which will
reside typically on a web server. And this
is the one that - Interacts with the
browser on the end client. And the presentation
logic that I mentioned to you earlier is
provided in a container, which is called a web
container, and this is the guy that is
responsible for dynamically perhaps creating the pages that have
to be sent by the web server back to the browser of the client. And there is
an EJB container, which is the one that
manages the business logic that corresponds to what needs
to be done in order to carry out the
request that is come in from the end client.
And there may be a database server, that the
business logic is communicating with in order to Get access
to the data that it needs to process the
request that came in. So these are the four
containers: the client container, the applet container, the web
container and the EJB container that are, the containers that
are available for packaging the objects
that constitute. The entire application for
providing a particular service, for example,
airline reservation service or a hotel reservation
service. The key hope is that we want to exploit as much as possible, reuse
components, and for this purpose continuing sort of the coffee analogy starting
with Java. The word bean is used to indicate a unit of reels, that is, a bundle
of Java objects providing a specific functionality. For example, there may be
a bean that provides the shopping cart
function. So that becomes a unit that reuse
in constructing an N-tier application. The containers
that I talked about here host the beans.
That is, a container allows you to package
a whole bunch of Java beans and make it
available in this container, in the JEE framework.
There are four types of beans, one type of
bean is called an entity bean. For instance
an entity bean maybe a row of a database.
If you think about the database holding employee records
for instance, one drawer of the database may correspond
to all the employees whose last names
start with the alphabet," a". And typically
entity beans are persistent objects with primary
keys. And the persistence for the entity bean
may be built into the bean itself and that is what is called bean management
persistence, or it may be built into the container into which that entity bean
is instantiated. In either case Since we are
dealing with objects that may need persistence, it
is important that the persistance for that object
is handled somewhere either in the entity itself
or the container into which that entity is
being hosted. The second type bean is what
is called a session bean. And the session
bean typically is associated with a particular client.
And a particular session, meaning a temporal
window over which a client is interacting with
the service. That is what a session bean may be holding. And a session bean
could be a stateful session bean, meaning,
for instance, I am ordering, let's say, a
computer, by contacting a portal for Del.
In that case, the session that I'm establishing
with the Del portal, that session has to be stateful, because it has to remember
what choices I'm making. I may actually keep those choices alive, go away for a
while, come back the next day, and
continue with my purchase. So, sessions could be
stateful. There could also be stateless sessions. For
instance if I start an email session using
my browser with Google using Gmail, that session maybe
stateless. I go away, everything that I did during
that session can be thrown away because I'm going
to start a brand new session when I re initiate
a connection with a G mail server. So in
that sense, a session bean could be a state-full session
bean or a stateless session bean. And the third
type of bean is what is called a message-driven bean.
This kind of bean is useful for asynchronous
behavior. For instance, I might be interested in
getting the stock quotes, I might have a
stock quote ticker on my browser and I might
want to get updates on the movement of
stocks of a particular company that I'm interested
in. And that would be something that is
accomplished using a message bean. Which is having this
asyncrhonous behavior. Stock ticker is an example,
news feed is an example, RSS feeds that
you typically are using, these days, are
examples of message driven beans. And the finer
we make these beans, each of these beans is denoting a functionality, but if you
can have fine grained Versions of these
beans. That gives a greater opportunity to enhance
a concurrency for dealing with an individual request
that's coming into your application's server, or there could
be concurrent requests. In addition to my own request,
there could be parallel requests coming in. All of
those can be dealt with more concurrently if
we implement these beans at a finer level of
granularity. But if you implement the bean at a
finer level of granularity that means that the business
logic is also getting more complex. So, there
is always this trade off in structuring end clear
applications that we made have a complex business
logic In order to support finer grain concurrency or
I might choose to keep the business logic
very simple and use [UNKNOWN] beans. And this is
where the core of what we are going to discuss
lies, and that is. We are going to discuss.
Different design alternatives for structuring such entity application servers.